you asked me to watch south park medical
scene i said get this comment to 10 000
likes and you did it so let's watch it
no shots no shots eric you have to be a
big boy
big boys get a toy from the toy chest
see the doctor's getting it wrong
you have to give the toy first earn the
trust then have the shot be injected
[Music]
and don't let them visualize the shot
it's scary to look at that keep it on
the side keep it out of their vision
have them look elsewhere
this is like a scene out of a horror
movie
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm sorry but i have a lot of other
patients to see we'll just have to try
again next week
come on eric we're going home we gotta
help me promise
let's go get in the car why is he still
nude
and no you shouldn't leave the office
just because the child doesn't want the
vaccinations vaccinations are incredibly
important part of growing up and growing
up healthy and safe so yes please get
your children vaccinated and don't let
them
walk around nude in a medical office
like that that's just strange what have
we got
not sure it looks like a possible code
five six kidding shut up kenny i'm not
sure if he has pink eye
or is that like a uh subconjunctival
hemorrhage which is actually really
benign in most cases the way that the
paramedics brought him in there pretty
legit minus the fact they said he's code
five six that is not
medical jargon i'm sorry south park get
me 50 cc's of ketamine stat
and get something for the kid too oh
that was actually really funny
ketamine is a tranquilizer it's
technically uh it started as an animal
tranquilizer and now we've actually
found some medical uses for it in humans
i actually have a whole video on this
talking about how ketamine infusions are
being used for
treatment resistant depression link down
below
his ekg is showing that he's like a
failing stock market
stock what is happening and his ekg next
to his bedside i don't know what that is
that's not a medical rhythm i'm afraid
he's
running out of time why what's wrong
with him
it's his time it's running out well what
does he need
he needs to have more time oh my god
this reminds me of the movie out of time
with justin timberlake that was such a
good movie where like time is money
literally time was money because time is
money but money is not time
and then if you have enough time you run
out of money
i'm lost
sweetie what i'm is
oh my god eric help me
help me
is this a medical condition well all his
vital signs are still normal from his
outward appearance i would say he has
the standard skin pigment deficiency
you mean yes i'm afraid that your son is
suffering from
gingivitis but how can i become a ginger
now
to play on gingivitis which is
inflammation of the gums but there's
actually been a lot of misconceptions
about folks who have red hair
specifically in the medical community
there was a thought where they tested
individuals with red hair and they found
they required more anesthesia than other
patients however once we've
expanded the research to have more
patients we found that to be completely
untrue so there's a lot of myths about
folks with red hair
of them being emotional needing more
medication for anesthesia
none of this is proven what's the saying
sam when something is like
uh like legend has
it's it urban legend you need to
understand there is no cure
your son will be ginger his whole life
for individuals who do have very light
skin pale skin like this
and for individuals who have a high
number of moles on their body you
actually at a higher risk for developing
skin cancers and sunburns so please
shade is your friend spf is your next
best friend you're gonna have to take
certain precautions now
it's very important that you keep eric
out of the sun oh
my favorite part about that is not that
he confirmed my diagnosis of being
careful with the sun but the fact that
he went to the university of the
mountains
i don't know what to do sharon they want
to have him go into surgery but that's
so dangerous
sheila have you tried holistic natural
medicines they work wonders i read all
about it in people
really in people there's a brand new
shop in town that sells holistic
medicines and all natural foods it's run
by this fascinating woman named
miss information that reminds me of goop
i don't know why
i'm getting gwyneth paltrow vibes from
this although i have one major
correction here holistic
does not mean frou-frou holistic does
not mean naturopathic holistic
means whole person in fact when i treat
my patients i treat them with holistic
care
i give them medical care sometimes it's
a natural lifestyle based approach
sometimes it's a medication based
approach sometimes it's surgical if a
person comes in with a heart attack i
don't just say oh that's the heart
attack patient no we think about what's
going on in their lives how can they eat
better what can they do to start
exercising once it's safe to do so what
medication should they be on can they
afford these medications what's going on
in their personal life like if you think
about all these variables you're gonna
have a better chance of getting that
person healthier wow i just went on a
rant about south park
you see the reasons our bodies fail is
because of toxins
toxins all the horrible food we eat the
sodas and meats are filled with toxins
and the only way for us to get better is
to flush those toxins out of our system
and i wonder how we get rid of toxins we
have body parts that actually do it for
us surprise surprise the lungs do it the
kidneys do it the liver does it it gets
out those evil toxins you know what's
funny about the trigger where toxins you
know you can scare people into buying
something that they don't need you don't
even know what a toxin is when you say
it like water is an essential component
of my being but if i have too much of it
i can actually dilute my body's
electrolyte so much so that i can kill
myself essentially by drinking too much
water the toxicity of a substance can
really only be dictated by the
dose so don't let people scare you when
they throw around words like that mrs
braflowski would like to give your son
herbs that focus on the kidney
i have these excellent herbs from local
native americans oh
native americans now they know how to
heal the body spiritually
how did it go from holistic care to
spiritual care in one herbal second
hi doctor what can i do for you well
it's my friend kyle
i think he's really really sick he is
really really sick stanley your little
friend kyle needs a kidney transplant or
is very possible that
he will die why does kyle need a kidney
transplant that's an aggressive
procedure like he needs to have
something
tremendously wrong with both of his
kidneys to need and warrant a kidney
transplant i need to know the indication
for this
i'm taking this too seriously there's
only one person in south park with the
same blood type as kyle
[Music]
kyle's in trouble carmen i can see him
getting worse right before my eyes
there might be a way that you can save
his life uh-huh
what kyle really needs is a new kidney
will you donate one of your kidneys to
kyle
you only need one bad boy dude one of
your friends is gonna die don't you see
how serious this is for the record
humans have two kidneys and only need
one kidney to live in fact
there are some individuals who actually
have only one kidney and do great but if
something happens to their kidney like
it could happen to anybody else to both
of their kidneys they don't have a
backup
so it becomes more dangerous free range
aspirin all natural cell phones
free range aspirin it just hit me what
that is
i don't know why i found that so funny
oh hi stanley look i'm buying you some
more all natural toothpaste
you mean the stuff that tastes like
doesn't fight cavities that's right
look um i know that you all think the
earth and its natural healing powers can
cure kyle but the doctor at the hospital
told me it can't
well of course the doctor told you that
because he wants to make money
holistic medicine is about nature and
it's free
yet she's standing in front of a cash
register asking for a deposit
233 for 233
okay here we go okay well here goes
nothing
help me pull this pajamas up okay
i think this goes without being said
don't get a wood saw
and operate on your friend who needs a
kidney transplant
at home i don't know who needs to hear
that
but i'm just putting out there into the
ether
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
who just wakes up from a nap missing a
kidney give me back my kidney dude
please kyle needs it it's
men not yours man give it back right now
or there's gonna be hell to pay corrado
right here
that actually looks like a good kidney
wow well done south bar why hello there
eric
you see that that's man stan took my
kidney and i need to put back in
please oh i see are you sure that now
that it's already out you don't want to
just let your friend kyle have it
no because it doesn't belong to her it
belongs to me
it's men well all right then we'll get
you prepped for surgery
if you'll just sign this release thank
you how are you feeling bobby
better thanks you look a lot better yeah
looks like western medicine really did
the trick kyle's all better cartman
thanks to you it was all a trick
your mama did the kidney blocker and
then we put ketchup in your bed so you'd
think we took your kidney
yes but it was all just a trick to get
you to come in and sign this release
what's worse nurse jackie in the episode
that i watched
if she forged his organ donor
certificate on the back of his license
that's
crazy or them tricking cartman to sign
away his own kidney by thinking he's
actually getting his kidney put back
in what is happening with the ethics on
these shows
i also watched simpsons and reviewed the
medical scenes in that bad boy check it
out and enjoy the laugh
as always stay happy and healthy
i just want to say pee whoop one more
[Music]
time